et oui l'espagne a administré 18% des
doses de vaccins reçus ce sont un peu
plus de sept cent quarante mille doses
qui ont été distribués à travers le pays
et se sont un peu moins de 140 mille
espagnols qui ont été vaccinées alors
plusieurs raisons expliquent ce retard
selon le gouvernement il ya tout d'abord
les avions qui transportait ces doses
qui ont mis plus de temps à arriver que
prévu mais aussi les frigos adéquat pour
conserver ses doses dont certains
venaient du royaume uni alors la période
des fêtes a également été compliqué en
raison des nombreux jours fériés et
niveau organisation pour ne pas manquer
de personnel dans les hôpitaux et les
centres de santé les professionnels
volontaires doivent vacciner sur des
journées complémentaire alors dans son
plan de vaccination l'espagne a établi
une liste des populations prioritaires
ce sont donc les résidents des ehpad et
leur personnel soignant qui se font
vacciner en priorité alors l'espagne
aurait voulu accélérer la cadence en
prenant exemple sur son plan de
vaccination contre la grippe qui selon
elle fonctionne très bien pour immuniser
à grande échelle alors le gouvernement
se montre quand même très confiant pour
les prochaines semaines il assure que
d'ici les mois de mai et juin
ce sont 20 millions d'espagnols qui
seront vaccinés